coucou jeu
l'europe attend sa première conférence
de presse finale et on est super
contentes et on s'est plu à 7 heures du
matin merci beaucoup
[Musique]
histoire actuellement à d'autres
pour cet échec
les chèvres de montbazon qui joue pas
toujours cacher un peu gâché un peu
quelqu'un peut cacher un peu différent
parce qu'à chaque fois je suis un peu
caché en plus quelqu'un peut cacher un
peu gâché en fait caché en plus
quelqu'un peut cacher un peu que je suis
enfin quelqu'un peut cacher un peu gâché
en fait caché entre le cap à gauche
[Musique]
sur le pont d'avignon
on est dans ce bon bilan sur le monde
on est dans tout
les belles dames faut comme ça les
messieurs font comme ça
sur la pente avignon on dit danses
andines ans sur fond
avignon
on y danse de tout son long
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le pont d'avignon
on y danse on y danse sur le pont
d'avignon
on y danse de tous auront toutes les
dames fou comme ça
les messieurs font comme ça
sur le pont d'avignon handed en se
fondant sur le pont d'avignon
on y danse de temps
je
sur le pont d'avignon on dit dans ce
continent sur le pont tarillon
on y danse
oui c'est cette structure pas 4000 ans
mais presque vous contant web
sauf que c'est palais des papes et je
crois que il ya quatre mille ans n'y
avait pas ou la religion
c'est pour ça que je dis ou presque a
tenu presque on est aux dédicaces
bien que des gens qu'on connaît
c'est un concert dédicace assez
particulier puisque du vélo mais langues
sont ici ont eu l'idée a fleuri en du
génial que la série n'a eu quand ils se
soldent peu dédicacé et foods numéro
très délicate
voilà
on a des jolis petits mots oui j'ai
cherché un mot comme en corse comme
ailleurs des sports twitter c'est moi
c'est moi et très bien
la chaîne musicale la nouvelle individu
vient d'arriver pour gildas
géopolitique d'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à